[Music]
one of the panels that you moderated was
the Black Panther yeah I did Marvel and
Marvel had Marvel the Marvel panel
really was how you should do a panel was
like an hour and 15 minutes and it was
all these great movies and they you know
like Benedict Cumberbatch was there for
Doctor Strange and I showed footage from
the new spider-man movie would I it's
kind of like a John Hughes film by just
great guardians of the galaxy to James
done go and did a great job and black
panther was this big announcement
because the black panther character was
phenomenal in civil war so they said
well we're gonna do a movie so backstage
before the panel I was talking to
chadwick boseman and ryan coogler and
Lupita Nyong'o and Michael B Jordan and
I don't you guys I'm sure you know Danai
gurira who plays Michonne on Walking
Dead gonna be in the Black Panther movie
right so Lupita says hey everyone get in
a picture and I'm not in the cast so I
was going to stay out of that and then
deny goes get in here
so I look up and it's the coolest
picture except for my dumb dorky face I
think we have this picture here yeah
[Applause]
so that goes up and for like a half a
second I feel like oh this is a really
cool picture until this guy from
Nashville named Josh Raby tweeted you
have the tweet I think bring it up the
tweet here you're about to snap the most
badass office selfie of all time but the
dude from accounting law summed up I
apologize for a really bad picture up
I'm very excited about Black Panther
you